inflation in the united states is at a
40-year high we are literally watching
the official numbers creep in on 8
the unofficial number is likely in the
double digits the average american is in
a worse dire financial position than
they literally were just a year ago and
so ultimately the federal reserve they
had to do something and yesterday they
decided they were going to raise
interest rates by 25 basis points that
is the equivalent of bringing a water
gun to an actual inflation war this is
going to have almost no impact what do i
mean well we can see the interest rates
themselves have been coming down for
quite a while we go ahead and we look at
this chart since 1980 or so we have
watched interest rates continue to fall
only one way back in 2015 2016 we tried
to raise the rates again but obviously
had to go ahead and drop them
aggressively when the pandemic hit and
so if you look on the far right you can
see a little little blip that's the
interest rate raise that they've gone
after 25 basis point increase in the
interest rate is not going to do a thing
when it comes to inflation in fact the
inflation in march is likely to be
higher than what the inflation reading
was for february and so ultimately the
fed is going to have to decide what are
they going to do moving forward how much
fortitude do they have in terms of
continuing to do this exact activity
we've got a quote here from jerome
powell the federal reserve chairman what
he says is that we are attentive to the
risks of further upward pressure on
inflation and inflation expectations the
committee is determined to take the
measures necessary to restore price
stability the us economy is very strong
and well positioned to handle tighter
monetary policy so ultimately he remains
committed he is going to use that tight
monetary policy to address inflation and
try to get the economy into a place that
is better for the average american we
also can see here with the fomc
statement that in addition to the
committee expects to begin reducing its
holdings of treasury securities and
agency debt and agency mortgage-backed
securities at a coming meeting so it's
not just the manipulation of the
interest rate upwards as one of the
tools to go ahead and address inflation
they also are going to take a number of
other measures and the big question
right now across financial markets the
question that people are waging
trillions and trillions of dollars on
can the federal reserve get inflation
under control
and have some sort of soft landing so
that they avoid pushing us into a
recession i can't tell the future but
what i know is that that's going to be a
really tough task for them to accomplish
hey you did you like this video great we
make five of them a day and post them
here on this channel make sure you
subscribe like the video and see you
next time